are you close were you dad I'd never met
my dad single parent you never met my
dad so thanks for bringing that up
I don't know mine either mine's name is
Joe Rogan [ __ ] he's out there someplace
he's out there yeah I've never met my
dad and then I thought people did you
ever want to meet your dad did you ever
see you know what's funny my mom when I
met him I knew him until I was like six
oh that's worse
I'd never knew so I think that that's
when you if you know him a little bit
and then they're gone that sucks what
good thing is it it made me realize that
you can't count on people but you you
can't have trust issues
become someone that people count on
right and count on people that's what
you do I have a tight group of friends
like me and my friends are very close
I get it I would do anything for my
friends and family to see I have a
certain there's a certain level loyalty
that I have because of that kind of that
yeah will you understand it where
someone who grows up in a big household
filled with people and the family was
always there and everyone was there you
might take people for granted a little
bit you know whereas for me camaraderie
and closeness and all that that [ __ ]
means a lot to me it's very very
important I remember asking my mom about
my dad when I was like I don't know
17 18 you know and she got really
offended you know I raised you and you
know and that made me think like I was
like but women have their secrets like
they had their things and I didn't want
her to I never I don't regret your cry I
didn't want to pry and I didn't want to
find out like maybe he wanted to be in
my life but my mom was like no who knows
you know my mom she could have been
vindictive like that but I don't know
but I didn't hold it against her but she
told me his name and she was like if you
want to do this on your own you're that
kind of thing and I had the name for
like a week and then I forgot it and
that told me that it didn't matter so I
had ever since I never worried about it
good for you yeah it's there's some
people that it bothers them for their
whole life I mean one thing I don't know
when you have kids your bond with your
kids it's like it's I mean I would
assume that everyone's bond with their
children is very tight because it's a an
unbelievable love connection that you
have with children it's a true
unconditional
it's not just true unconditional it's
like they they're a drug like they give
you they give you love to the point
where like my daughter my my youngest
was we were playing the other day in the
pool and there's a point in time we were
just laughing about something together
just laugh and I'm looking at her face
and she's laughing and I felt like I was
on drugs I was like love that I have for
these people is so it's so intense it's
it's and it's also I didn't get that
when I was kid I didn't know exam man
the parents might you know my mom worked
my stepdad was a really good guy but no
one was ever around you know there's
just there was no and when they were
done work and everybody was tired you
know I was a latchkey kid you know when
when I was like 7 years old I live in
San Francisco I would go out and do a
magic show on Fisherman's Wharf by
myself just wander around the city just
they would open the door you just leave
7:00 I can't imagine that I spent a lot
of time by myself too because my mom was
working and myself I don't trying trying
to like trying to make it trying to make
sure that I had a good life by myself
you know Eric if you have kids with this
young lady or another young lady your
connection with that kid will be it'll
blow your [ __ ] mind
don't change who you are I feel like
that's what I've been lacking that's why
I've been more open to you know thinking
about these kinds of things you seem
like a dad yeah Wow cuz I'm writing I'm
picturing you a dad right my whole life
I've been like you know I've been like
that role for so many people in my life
right holding a baby and over drugs
that's crazy so that's why we still like
I always feel like you have already had
one of my best friends in the world is
like someone that I that's like I've had
to take care of you know he's had a
little drinking problem and yeah but
I've been there the whole time and I and
even though people would be like you
know you you you have to like you know
that people that think that you know yes
I'm hit rock bottom and get but I just
not like that yeah I've been through
that too I had a very good friend of
mine it's my best friend who died of
heroin and he was always [ __ ] up there
was always something it was always he
had a crack problem for a while and then
he got on pills and it was he was either
snorting it or it was like he already
lying very much reminds me of this guy
and Joey Diaz did a little bit too when
I first met Joey it was like right after
my friend Johnny well is right before
Johnny had died Johnny was still alive
but I known people like Joey because of
my friend Johnny but you know just I
always was there for him I was always
trying to take care of him I was always
trying to help him but it's just he was
always there was always something going
wrong and it never it but there was
these brief moments man where he'd be
fine and we'd be laughing and we'd have
the best time and that's why you fight
for it it's those times because I was
always I was always thinking that one
day who's gonna get it together I the
same thing with my friend is like it's
still going on with me right now it's
like you know when you have when you
deal with someone that deals with
depression real depression you know lost
his mother and you know and how that
affected his whole life and it's like so
I'm there needs younger than me so I
feel this mentorship and I just feel
like a loyalty that I just can't shake
right so I you know so that's that and I
know when I said when I go to therapy I
I want to ask why am i this way right
you know and then I realized that comedy
has been dampering my own depressions or
my own feelings because I feel like I'm
dealing with it in some way so while
sometimes I go and talk about things and
I talk about things in a way I just no
holds bar because I want to I want to
get this out right hey I feel like this
you know or if I don't like something
and and then combine that with we live
in a society right now where people
don't want to necessarily hear an
opinion that is not theirs
well there's definitely a little of that
right and so then therefore we get this
like it becomes is tougher and tougher
to do what we do but it's not gonna stop
me from doing it but that's it's sweeter
and sweeter when you pull it off you
know especially yeah controversial [ __ ]
yeah just got to navigate the waters
exactly what I feel like I've been I've
been doing it I think I did it with this
special I think I tried to talk about
things in a way where I was like okay
you may not agree but you don't have to
vilify me you know you don't have to
like you know you know but I'm anyway it
all goes back to like you know like who
we are as people because of like our
parents you know you know and it's like
I my I love my mom I love my stepdad
that's a great guy I'm glad he's in my
mom's life you know they're off in Spain
right now they moved to Spain like like
I say like a year and a half ago
so they're there you know and I'm happy
that she's happy in the later part of
her life that's awesome